[موسيقى]
زلاتان يشجع الارجنتين في كاس العالم
وميسي يصل الى ابو ظبي ونيمار يستعرض
مهاراته قبل المونديال هذه الاخبار وغيرها
تتابعونها على العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
لو رشحتم فريقا للفوز بكاس العالم فسيكون
منتخب الارجنتين والكلام على لسان اسطوره
كره القدم السويديه زلاتان ابراهيموفيتش
حديث ونجم اي سي ميلان الايطالي جاء خلال
جلسه الحواريه نظامها معرض الشرق الدولي
للكتاب في دورته الحاديه والاربعين واضاف
زلاتان امنوا ان ارى ميسي يحمل كاس العالم
فهذه الكاس الوحيده التي لم يحملها بعد
كما صرح زلاتان برغبته في تحويله كتابه
انا زلاتان الى فيلما في الماء
مين جهه وصل النجم الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي
الى العاصمه الاماراتيه ابو ظبي للانضمام
للمعسكر التدريبين منتخب بلاده تحضيرا
لمونديال قطر ويتخلل المعسكر لقاء ودي مع
منتخب الامارات يوم الاربعاء المقبل
واتوجه الارجنتين في المونديال السعوديه
والمكسيك والطولندا
[موسيقى]
صوت اكثر من 33 مليون شخص لاختيار
الشخصيات والانديه الفائزه بجائزه في كلوب
سكر الحدث العالمي الذي تستضيف دبي في
السابعه عشر من نوفمبر الحالي سيكرم
الفائزين في مختلف الفئات التي تبلغ 16
فئه للرياضيين لاعبين ومدربين واداريين
وكذلك انت وخمس فئات للعاملين في التخصصات
الداعمه والالكترونيه اضافه الى جوائز
الخاصه
استعرض النجم البرازيلي نيمار مهارات
الكرويه من ارتفاع 35 مترا عندما حذفت
اليه كره استقبلها نجوى باريس سان جيرمان
وسيطر عليها باتقان ويلعب نيمار مع منتخب
بلاده البرازيل في مونديال قطر ضمن مجموعه
صربيا وسويسرا والكاميرا
[موسيقى]